coup de jeune pour le service de
médecine nucléaire du centre hospitalier
de versailles depuis le mois de mai les
trois médecins travaillent dans leurs
nouveaux locaux avec du matériel de
pointe de gamma caméra et un tep scan
des appareils permettant un meilleur
accueil des patients en diminuant
notamment les délais d'attentes pour une
médecine particulière dans la médecine
nucléaire en étudie tous les organes
loos le coeur le poumon si vous voulez
en utilisant différentes de différents
produits radioactifs pour la tomographie
d'émission de posy temps pour le moment
on étudie beaucoup la cancérologie
mais on peut faire de la neurologie dans
la maladie d'alzheimer on peut
rechercher des infections on peut
étudier les vascularite etc etc
ces locaux s'intègre dans le projet
maternité néonatologie scintigraphie et
réanimation pour un coût global de 48
millions d'euros dont 9 sont apportés
par l' agence régionale de santé mur en
béton plein protection en plomb pour le
personnel zones froides zones chaudes
la réglementation est stricte le zonage
est important parce que la zone froide
c'est la zone qui est accessible à
n'importe qui tout public peut y accéder
les zones réglementées elles ne sont
accessibles qu'aux personnels qui est
habilité c'est à dire qu'il ya eu la
formation pour qui a les moyens de
radioprotection peau et qui a les
appareils de dosimétrie poursuivre sa
deuxième et riz et qui est formé au
poste de travail depuis plus d'un mois
le secteur tep scan réalise 5 à 6 examen
par jour le premier patient a été
accueilli dans le service le 12 mai